18 und fragmente eines unterkiefers ein fund in der sogenannten müssen die
Höhle im karmel-gebirge der forschungsteams staunen lässt denn die bislang ältesten überreste des homo sapiens
außerhalb von afrika verraten damit überraschende erkenntnisse zum leben und der
wanderrouten der modernen menschen
Im klartext die bekannte out of africa theorie also die theorie wie die menschen aus afrika gekommen sind muss wohl neu geschrieben werden
Ihr habt euch dieses thema in der whatsapp community gewünscht link am ende des videos und bekommt jetzt alle interessanten effekt zu diesem
Überraschungs kunden in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja vielleicht hat das auch noch, so im geschichtsunterricht gelernt nach bisherigen erkenntnissen entstand der homo sapiens vor rund 300.000 jahren in afrika
Doch die bislang ältesten fossilen funde die eindeutig dem homo sapiens
zuzuordnen sind sind nur rund
160000 jahre alt doch genetische hochrechnungen ließen forschungsteams weltweit dennoch von der entstehung unserer vorfahren vor rund
300.000 jahren ausgehen vor etwa 60 bis 120 tausend jahren soll der moderne mensch laut der sogenannten out of africa theorie
dann afrika verlassen haben das zeigen funde aus dieser zeit die aktuellen funde aus der
Höhle die nur einige kilometer von der hafenstadt haifa entfernt ist wegen jetzt aber
nahe dass die menschlichen vorfahren schon sehr viel früher afrika den rücken gekehrt haben nämlich ganze
50.000 jahre vorher als bisher gedacht also von mindestens
177 1000 jahren das forschungsteam von der universität tel aviv hat mit verschiedenen platzierungs methoden gearbeitet
Und so das alter der acht zähne und oberkiefer fragmente bestimmt
unterschiedliche methoden die in verschiedenen untersuchungen und laboren angewandt worden ergaben
übereinstimmende und wirklich beeindruckende erkenntnisse demnach haben die fossilien ein alter zwischen
1194 1000 jahre der aktuelle fund stützt übrigens eine studie aus dem vergangenen jahr eines forschungsteams vom
max-planck-institut für
menschheitsgeschichte in jena die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler hatten aufgrund einer gen analyse die hypothese aufgestellt dass der moderne mensch früher als bisher angenommen
Afrika verlassen hatte nämlich vor etwa 200.000 jahren die neue studie stützt
zudem weitere aktuelle erkenntnisse von evolution szenegängern ein forschungsteam aus leipzig hat dem letzten jahr dna
untersuchungen gemacht die nahelegen dass sich die wege von homo sapiens und neandertaler schon 430 bis
145 1000 jahren gekreuzt hatten zur info etwa vier prozent des menschlichen erbguts stammen von
neandertalern, also ließ schon dieses schuljahrs leipzig vermuten dass sich der homo sapiens bereits
230.000 jahren außerhalb von afrika
Herumgetrieben hat und es dort eben auch, zu sexuellen konnte packen kann doch der aktuelle von
Korrigiert nicht nur die out of africa theorie sondern gibt auch hinweise darauf wie die modernen menschen von ost afrika
Nach asien gelangen sind denn dazu werden zwei routen diskutiert der eine weg führt über ägypten und die sinai-halbinsel
Die andere route führt vom heutigen äthiopien über die arabische halbinsel
der jetzt entdeckte
fundort spricht dafür
Dass der homo sapiens wohl zunächst über das niltal kam es war der beginn der besiedlung der gesamten erde durch den menschen den homo sapiens
Es ist jetzt also noch früher
Passiert und vielleicht gibt es da bald noch mehr und noch genauere erkenntnisse wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann schicke ich euch vor allen anderen einen link zum neuesten video
Garantiert ihr könnt dort auch direkt in der redaktion von krieg so mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
Fragen zu videos stellen es ist quasi der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke ihr wisst genau
Vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken der mensch ist hunderttausend jahre älter ja das passt auch
Zu den neuesten erkenntnissen an sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran